legion stadium was built to be home to
the nfl's las vegas raiders to be a cash
cow for our city and southern nevada
a structure that would help pump
millions into our local economy
the state bid on the building and pledge
790 million dollars a bet
that is all of southern nevada now
watching very closely as
kovit has crippled our tourism-based
economy
las vegas was hopping a year ago room
tax dollars were feeding the state's
appetite for this two billion dollar
mansion at a rate of nearly 4 million
per month
january 2020 was the biggest gain then
kobit crushed las vegas
room tax dollars disappeared but payment
obligations do not
as we sit here right now in january of
2021
the stadium authority board has about
a little over 57 million dollars in
reserves
which is enough to fully fund the bond
payments over the next 18
months that's a year and a half to pay
off city debts if las vegas became a
ghost town with two reserve funding
pools the authority board has been
forced to dip its toes into those waters
two years of the same lockdown and
they'd be drowning in debt with no
safety net with a tourism-based economy
there is no city like the sports
entertainment capital of the world so
when sports starts drying up like we've
seen this past year the lost revenue is
staggering
it's measured in the billions of dollars
there are two types of travelers to las
vegas the special event traveler stays
longer spends more money and when you
factor in those
visitors the economic impact is
eye-popping
the gross economic impact and that's the
total spend
in everything that happens and i'm
telling you i think that that's well in
excess of a billion dollars probably
approaching two billion dollars those
are real dollars lost when nascar the
nfr pbr
conference basketball tournaments boxing
ufc college bowl games
wnba unlv sports vegas golden nights and
any other sporting event
closes its doors but there's hope on the
las vegas horizon
and it's sports i don't think there's
going to be any greater sign
of las vegas resurgence than a allegiant
stadium
filled with 65 screaming raiders fans
that broadcast to 16 million people
all over the united states and many ways
all over the world
showing that las vegas is opening las
vegas will rebound it carries weight
that name
las vegas it's resilient it's built by
winners who came before us
and even during a pandemic people are
still moving into
las vegas some people vote with their
feet in that way
it sort of is an indication of the the
the good that has been done by those who
came before us
place your bets ladies and gentlemen all
right now jeremy did point out that if
we're having the same conversation
in terms of room tax dollars in two
years then we have a much bigger problem
than funding a stadium
in this community